[Musique]
ce soir une enquête bouleversante sur la
fin de vie de trois jeunes patients
cancéreux de l'hôpital sainte justine
tout s'est passé assez vite ces trois
six mois si les soins palliatifs
avant de mourir les notes gêné free
guillaume ont participé à une étude
clinique
y a plus tard été suspendu par santé
canada une étude qui soulève de grandes
questions éthiques
on veut pas être des cobayes positionner
des cobayes qu'on le sache ces jeunes
patients étaient condamnés mais ont-ils
souffert inutilement dans des essais
cliniques
quand quelque chose va même se produire
à ma mère à ces questions s'ajoute celle
de la menace qui se cachaient dans
l'étude du plafond
côté région cutanées douloureuses
c'était par la clau j'espère c'est parce
que je parle c'est ça ressemble un
chasseur chapillon mais il faut pour
cela soit si je vous dis faut pour que
ce poisson
pascal thurre bd yannick lapointe ont
découvert des faits troublants sur une
étude clinique menée par le très
respecté hôpital pour enfants
sainte-justine jeu les bus quand même
sourit blanche dans un aquarium
bienvenue à enquête
[Musique]
7 novembre 2016 c'est un grand jour pour
l'hôpital sainte-justine ministres et
dignitaires célèbre l'ouverture du tout
nouveau centre de recherche et donc pas
uniquement des locaux
c'est aussi une nouvelle façon de faire
une nouvelle façon d'être
le bâtiment moderne et coloré occupe la
partie ouest de l'hôpital pour enfants
mais au même moment dans la partie est
de l'hôpital un drame se joue depuis
cinq jours des inspecteurs saisissent
des dossiers fouilles dans les
ordinateurs et interroge les employés du
pavillon charles bruneau réservé aux
enfants cancéreux
c'est santé canada qui les envoient l'
agence fédérale vient de recevoir une
plainte anonyme au sujet de dec jane une
étude clinique destinée aux enfants dont
le cancer semble incurable
l'heure est grave la réputation d'un des
plus importants hôpitaux pédiatriques du
canada
est en jeu
[Musique]
au moment de l'inspection l'étude a
cessé ses opérations
une enfant a quitté à cause des effets
secondaires
quatre autres sont décédés et le dernier
des six mourra pendant le passage des
inspecteurs
quelques semaines plus tard la sanction
tombe santé canada suspens l'étude des
djeun santé canada estime qu'il n'est
pas justifié de poursuivre la phase 1 de
l'étude des effets indésirables graves
et des décès ont eu lieu au cours du
premier cycle de dosage
il n'a pas non plus été démontré qu'une
dose sécuritaire a été établi santé
canada recense 76 violations à la loi
sur les aliments et drogues dont 23 de
niveau critique c'est-à-dire constituant
un danger pour les sujets ou un risque
excessif qui menacent leurs droits leur
santé et leur sécurité
c'est hyper grave et surtout quand on a
le régulateur santé cardiaque et devient
et qu'ils l'ont glisse de problème avec
une étude
ça c'est majeur la liste est
effectivement très longue
les effets secondaires graves et un
décès non déclarés à santé canada des
dossiers mal tenues du personnel mal
formé et les médicaments périmés
ça démontre que l'étude a été mal
supervisé et mal monitorer le chercheur
john est un fils et dirige le
département de neuro oncologie du plus
gros hôpital pédiatrique des états unis
est-ce que santé canada a eu raison de
suspendre l'étude
beaucoup trop de violations ne pas
fermer l'étude était une heure
suspendre une étude clinique c'est
pourtant très rare santé canada ne l'a
fait que cinq fois depuis 2000 12 5 fois
sur 337 inspection je ne se fera pas
brune williams john dirige le
département de bioéthique de l'école de
santé publique de l'université de
montréal manque de documentation de
suivis de déclarations problématique se
parle d'un problème et sociaux neil dans
l'unité qui entend de faire la recherche
dans les rapports de santé canada dresse
le portrait d'une étude mal construites
et désorganisée dans un monde où la
précision la prudence et le respect de
la méthode scientifique compte plus que
tout dans des essais cliniques
surtout dans les essais cliniques on
suit la règle en chaque petit détail et
documenté est suivi l'équipe est formée
pour le faire c'est évident parce que on
est dans cette situation où quand
quelque chose va mal se pratique
vraiment mal c'est exactement ce que
dénonçaient des employés du centre de
recherche dans une lettre à la direction
des ressources humaines de sainte
justine
huit mois avant l'inspection de santé
canada on nous demande de ne pas
respecter les règles et des événements
qui devraient être rapportés à santé
canada dans des gènes ne le sont pas
cela mais la responsabilité de l'hôpital
en jeu sainte justine
les grands pour cette étude qualifiée de
première mondiale
douze patients pour commencer puis douze
autres plus tard dans d'autres hôpitaux
pour la première fois les chercheurs en
oncologie de sainte-justine on concevoir
et gérer leurs propres études cliniques
plutôt que celle d'une compagnie
pharmaceutique
une première étude maison et une
première suspension pour l'équipe de
saint justin
c'est la première fois dans un projet
qui fait l'objet d'un avis de non
conformité dans ce souk 6 une première
pour nous malheureusement l'étude d'agde
jeunes cherchaient à mesurer l'effet
combiné de deux molécules hla des sites
abine une chimiothérapie et la
génistéine un dérivé du soya une
combinaison qui selon sainte-justine
offrira un espoir de survie et de
guérison aux enfants qui n'en veut
ma femme est one moyenne son pharmacien
et ils sont aussi parents de trois
enfants liam eliane elena qui est
atteinte d'un cancer au cerveau
tout s'est passé assez vite elle avait
aucun symptôme jusqu'à 10 ont environ
deux semaines avant quelques gênes à
l'hôpital à l'hôpital et ils m'ont fait
attendre que pressé après un scalp une
heure après le médecin dit y'a plus rien
à voir
ces trois mois puis si les soins
palliatifs
c'est à ce moment que saint justin leur
propose des jane les nains sera la
première patiente
les parents de l'ena savent que leur
fille est condamné mais il accepte quand
même de s'engager dans l'étude avec elle
on a aimé le concept de l'étude parce
que cela ouvre une porte à un autre type
de traitement peut être un traitement
plus comme prometteur pour l'avenir leur
formation scientifique les incite à
poser des questions aux chercheurs
on m'a posé la question comment vous
allez déterminer la dose pour les moeurs
je me souviens que la réponse n'est pas
très doigts et poncé mais la question de
la dose elle était très pertinente comme
vous le comprendrez plus tard
antoine et son épouse savent déjà que
leur fille ne pourra pas s'en sortir
mais comme tous les parents nous
espérons mirare c'est pour ça que notre
façon on n'a plus rien à perdre
le miracle improbable n'est pas survenu
lina meurt de sa maladie 27 jours après
son premier traitement donc de tomber
avec votre fille dans le vide pour
espérer un remède pour prier le cnc
n'écoute pas prêt lattes à l'interné que
vous restez avec elle jusqu'à temps que
ce qui devait arriver c'était le 2
décembre 2015 il quitte l'hôpital et
n'entende plus parler de jane ni de ces
chercheurs comment vous avez su quelle
étude à laquelle a participé votre fille
avait été suspendu par santé canada
au fond on n'est pas au courant
vous avez jamais été informé de sa part
sainte justine non en fait c'est radio
canada qui le leur a appris ce que les
parents ne savaient pas non plus c'est
que leur fille avait reçu une dose de
chimiothérapie et rim et une déviation
du protocole signalé trois fois dans le
rapport de santé canada
le dossier médical lui révèle autre
chose c'est le médecin responsable de
l'étude
enrique bittencourt qui ordonne de
continuer la perfusion malgré le
dépassement de l'heure d'expiration
c'est grave c'est une étude de phase 1
pour leur stabilité du médicament nous
avons rencontré un oncologue de sainte
justine qui a traité plusieurs des
jeunes patients inscrits à l'étude
vous entendrez son récit tout le long de
ce reportage
mais comme il craint les répercussions
sur sa carrière nous avons demandé à un
comédien de relater son témoignage un
médicament qui n'est pas stable qui est
périmé
ça peut faire du menton donc on va
prendre des risques aux patients
le docteur michel duval dirige l'unité
d'hémato oncologie
il ne voit pas où est le problème il
s'agissait de quelques minutes
dépassement de leurs decks de leurs deux
fins de perfusion donc après quelques
minutes c'est acceptable
plus je pense que quelques minutes
différence sur 24 heures ne font pas de
différence dans les faits cette toxicité
l'ena n'a pas subi de conséquences
néfastes mais ses parents savent que les
résultats scientifiques peuvent être
mise en doute
si on va avoir des bons résultats pour
les autres puis on n'est même pas
capable de respecter le protocole en ce
moment là le résultat final des études
je pense qu'on peut mettre des points
d'interrogation là dessus ils ont
absolument résoudre ce que ça remet en
question la validité des résultats
qu'ils soient négatifs ou positifs les
autres la recherche est toujours
nécessaire mais ne bien fait
les recharges c'est beaucoup plus
important
y at il eu des pressions indues pour
convaincre les familles de participer à
l'étude
on vous révèle un enregistrement secret
après la pause 23 novembre 2016
deux semaines après la suspension de
l'étude devant un parterre de médecins
réunis à l'hôpital sainte justine le
docteur enric ebit en cours explique ce
qu'il espère accomplir avec jane le but
de cette étude s'est retrouvé la dose
idéale et surtout non toxique et pour la
deuxième partie de l'étude des questions
cette dose dans des patients avec les os
est ni ce que le docteur bittencourt ne
dit pas à ses collègues
c'est que son étude clinique vient
d'être suspendu il ajoute même que
l'étude est en cours ce n'est toutes
pièces un cours dans la phase 1 donc
j'espère d'ici deux ans qu'on va voir
des résultats plus concrets
quel chemin a mené cette étude vers
l'hôpital sainte justine
les deux mêmes molécules avait été testé
sur des souris en 2008 puis sur des
adultes à l'hôpital notre dame en 2015
l'équipe de sainte justine utilise le
mot encourageant pour décrire les
résultats de l'étude adultes
un constat étonnant selon l'un des
chercheurs de notre dame qui a accepté
de nous parler sous couvert de
l'anonymat
moi j'ai pas trouvé que c'était une
combinaison qui était particulièrement
efficace en grattant un peu il ya
quelques patients qui ont eu un petit
effet mais cliniquement ça n'avait pas
beaucoup de temps
c'est sur la base de ces résultats
adultes que les chercheurs soumettent
leurs protocoles à santé canada
le protocole c'est la bible d'une étude
clinique le document qui fait foi de
tout les protocoles comme vous le
décrivez m'a décrit superficiel et mal
documenté il aurait pu faire beaucoup
même s'il déplore l'absence de
raisonnement scientifique clair
l'éminent chercheur john est un fils y
croit tout de même que la combinaison
des citadines génistéine valait la peine
d'être explorée
au final j'ai trouvé le raisonnement à 6
c'était une idée astucieuse
à quoi sert une étude expérimentale en
cancer ce que le milieu appelle une
étude de phase 1 dans un phase on essaie
de comprendre
est ce que le médicament qu'on va tester
est toxique
le but c'est pas de vérifier si ça
marche on perd n'est ce pas un
traitement on peut pas c'est pas un
traitement c'est un intervention
expérimental qui vise à développer des
connaissances
le shass qui lie à un bénéfice est très
très faible
pourtant dans une lettre envoyée au
directeur de leur unité
les chercheurs de sainte-justine avance
que les études de phase 1 peuvent être
bénéfiques sur la survie des
participants d'entrée de 10 % déclarent
un pourcentage que saint justin maintien
dans la littérature qu'elle nous fournit
mais ce 10 % de bénéfices sur la survie
laisse nos experts perplexes
particulièrement john hutton qui m'amène
qui dirige l'unité d'éthique biomédicale
de l'université mcgill
il est un des experts mondiaux de
l'éthique des études expérimentales sur
le cancer
je n'ai jamais vu de pourcentage comme
cela la survie ça ne se mesure pas de
façon fiable dans les études de phase 1
donc ça n'a rien à voir avec les
chiffres que je connais pas moi qui ai
donc selon vous c'est faux je n'ai
aucune raison de penser que c'est vrai
que se passe-t-il lorsqu'un chercheur
présente son étude clinique à un patient
désespérés ou à ses parents
quels mots sont prononcés quels espoirs
suscités cette famille de laval va nous
ouvrir la porte de l'étude des gènes
même si elle était inquiète
elle montrait qu'elle avait encore
positive le coulage rouler sur le sec
[Musique]
mais la nageuse nerveuse peut-être parce
que jennifer savait ce qui l'attendait
elle avait enduré 5 chimio et une greffe
de moelle pour traiter de leucémie
différente lorsque l'hôpital de montréal
pour enfants laje faire à sainte-justine
n'afèr mères frères et soeurs
l'accompagnent steak sommes vraiment des
cinq qui travaillaient ensemble
elle n'est pas seule dans la bataille
comme pour toutes les rencontres
importantes
la famille enregistre la présentation du
médecin c'est plus efficace que de
prendre des notes simple c'est le
docteur yvan samson un des chercheurs
associés qui reçoit la famille en
anglais la langue parlée à la maison
c'est une étude de phase 1 le docteur
sens on le mentionne à quelques reprises
il doit en principe la présenter de
façon objective
le but premier n'est pas de guérir le
patient
est ce que vous saviez ce que c'était
une étude de phase 1 expérimentale
peut-être on on n'a pas compris vraiment
ces coins de phase 1 comment j'ai pas eu
l'impression qu'on était là pour cette
phase 1 cette époque là c'était pas
qu'est ce que j'avais compris mais il y
a un mot que tout le monde a compris un
mot qui frappe l'imaginaire de toute la
famille l'émission - en fait pour nous
c'était ça le mot qui en fait nous a
convaincus d'aller dans cette
cet essai clinique bien neuf fois durant
l'entretien le chercheur prononcera le
mot rémission hasard assuré tout bientôt
je côtoie ils évoquent jusqu'à 12 cycles
de chimio alors que le maximum reçu par
les autres patientes étaient un ou deux
cycles
mais ça la famille de jennyfer ne l'a
jamais su c'est la possibilité de
rémission qui a pris toute la place
son frère michael
s'il n'y avait pas de chances de
rémission je ne lirai pas conseillé dec
jane on avait d'autres options aux états
unis c'est ce qu'on avait choisi
l'éthicien brainwave james jones a
révisé pour nous la transcription
complète de cette rencontre
il ne s'explique pas pourquoi le
chercheur évoque à répétition la
possibilité de rémission dans une étude
expérimentale est sous l'eau liszt est
un mot qui appelait de chage émotionnel
dont on évite surtout dans une situation
où c'est que les gens sont
émotionnellement vulnérables d'utiliser
un langage qui peut être manipulateur un
langage qui sort un espoir qui est
irréaliste
ça c'est totalement injuste si vous
voulez la vérité pendant toutes ces
discussions avec tous les médecins à
travers les années et dix petits mois
c'est quoi mes chances dis moi ce que je
dois savoir et voulait pas être protégé
le chercheur mentionne à jennyfer qu'une
guérison est improbable il lui propose
aussi de réfléchir quelques jours c'est
ce qu'elle a l'intention de faire et
elle le dit mais quelques minutes plus
tard
we could do is today we have we
mémorisation me diane st régis bobigny
to do you want to belong to be recruté
comme bibi et qu'environ 18 en 2004
électrique
[Musique]
on est des jeux chez du lait une
intervention qui début de l'étude ils
ont pas encore signé le constamment ils
ont pas encore décidé s'il veut faire
nous oui ça c'est inadmissible
lié au rejet déclenchée avant que les
personnes signent le constat est clair
et ça c'est la pression et du yas mais
le problème le docteur yvon sens on n'a
pas souhaité participer aux reportages
l'hôpital sainte justine a mandaté le
biochimiste co responsable de l'étude
deux de ces patrons médecins et la
présidente du comité d'éthique pour
répondre à nos questions notamment sur
les possibilités de rémission très
certainement moi j'avais vu les données
de souris et avec ces données là je
n'aurait très certainement en discussion
une passion évoqué la possibilité d'une
émission en disant qu'elle était faible
et qui avec n'était pas impossible et
ton parent moi si on me disait votre
enfant il ya aucune chance de survie je
trouverais ça absolument immonde et pour
moi avoir c'est vrai parfois c'est vrai
mais nous notre réalité notre mission
c'est de leur proposer des alternatives
selon le professeur william stone voici
à quoi devrait ressembler une entrevue
de consentement véritablement déclaré
ils ont en fait ce n est féroce ce
domaine dans cet extrait d'une série
documentaire sur le cancer diffusé à
tibi est un chercheur et site la liste
détaillée et proportionnel de tous les
effets secondaires que l'enfant pourrait
subir
l'espoir des parents s'amenuisent
c'est un bon exemple exactement comment
bien faire ils sont ouvertes
ils sont en écoute il donne le temps et
met pas de pression mais une décision
qui semble avoir été difficile à prendre
pour jennyfer aussi plus de trois
semaines après la rencontre avec le
chercheur de sainte justine
elle signe le consentement et devient la
quatrième patiente de jane après la
pause l'histoire d'un petit garçon de 5
ans qui n'aurait pas dû être admis dans
l'étude
[Musique]
jennyfer a hésité avant d'accepter de
participer à l'étude des djeun son
dossier médical le révèle deux fois elle
demande plus de temps pour réfléchir car
elle craint les effets d'une sixième
chimio le 26 mai 2016
jennyfer reçoit sa première dose de des
six cabines elle était ma si fatigué et
fiévreuse depuis une semaine mais ses
parents gardent espoir
on possède toujours qu'on va sortir du
tunnel que tout va aller bien
on avait fait déjà pendant plus de six
ans il ya des matins mans il ya des
traitements
si une chanson va l'apprendre exact
[Musique]
je peux dire que la famille avait un
espoir énorme dans cette étude pour la
famille sainte justine était le bon dieu
[Musique]
c'est un colloque de sainte justine à
traiter jennyfer à plusieurs reprises il
a accepté de nous parler sous le couvert
de l'anonymat
c'est un comédien qui reprend ses propos
on est à la limite de l'acharnement
thérapeutique
elle avait le risque d'infection très
élevé à cause de fièvre
moi je trouve qu'elle était trop faible
pour être admise dans lé dessus même si
techniquement les critères étaient
respectées jenifer sera la première
leucémiques de l'étude
elle sera aussi la première à recevoir
une dose réduite parce que là des
citadines avait créé trop d'effets
toxiques chez les trois premières
patientes atteintes de tumeurs au
cerveau mais ses effets toxiques
les chercheurs les connaissait déjà il
était apparu chez les patients adultes
ceux de l'hôpital notre dame à une dose
de 120 mg or les premiers patients
enfants ont reçu 360 mg trois fois plus
pourquoi les chercheurs de
sainte-justine ont-ils tripler la dose
de départ de l'étude pédiatrique
l'oncologue j'en étais mme finley ne
comprends pas après avoir lu le
protocole comprenez vous pourquoi les
chercheurs ont triplé la dose pour
enfants ce nom parce que l'argumentaire
est superficiel et mal conçus vous
comprenez pas de raisonnement
scientifique mais le raisonnement n'est
pas documenté
pourquoi tripler la dose
selon des experts en pharmacologie à qui
nous avons soumis les protocoles les
enfants auraient dû recevoir une dose
similaire à celle déjà considéré
toxiques chez les adultes parce que
cette combinaison de molécules n'avait
jamais été testée chez les enfants ce
que plusieurs études ont démontré ce
qu'il fallait augmenter la durée d'un
fusion de ces médicaments là pour aller
obtenir une efficacité thérapeutique et
jusqu'à trépied
le nouveau dosage a été entérinée par le
comité scientifique de sainte justine
donc on savait que c'était une approche
qui était sécuritaire avec
éventuellement un potentiel de hausse
n'était pas inquiet de la toxicité
pourtant les mêmes chercheurs finiront
par reconnaître que la dose de départ
était trop élevé dans une lettre à leurs
patrons
il nous semble que la dose à être
utilisé dans le futur devra être
inférieure à la dose initiale
compte tenu de la toxicité très probable
jeune et fun ne recevra elle aussi
qu'une seule dose de des citadines
son état se dégrade rapidement et le 13
juin on diagnostique une faune j'ai mis
une infection à champignons possiblement
reliés à la des citadines un des
médecins qui l'a traité se souvient
réflexion est tellement sévère et
incontrôlable que le champignon
ils circulaient partout son infection
était vraiment aux amygdales à la base
de la langue donc celui boucher les
voies aériennes supérieures lever les
voies respiratoires complètement bloquée
jennifer a contracté un géo tri comme un
champignon très rares ce qui n'est pas
rare
c'est le risque de développer une
infection grave pour une personne dans
son état 39% selon le protocole lorsque
le docteur samson rencontre jennyfer
quelques semaines auparavant
il mentionne un risque d'infection
important mais sans donner de détails
est ce que ça aurait pu changer quelque
chose vous pensez à votre décision ou à
la sienne en fait à ce point là on
allait discuter avec jane pouvoir est ce
que c'est
l'escroc oui pour pour procéder ou parce
qu'on prend un autre chemin ou quoi
il faut le dire il faut savoir parce que
si on ne sait pas après on est un choc
le choc est venu moins d'un mois après
l'entrée de jennyfer dans l'étude
elle meurt le 23 juin 2016 d'un épisode
de détresse respiratoire aiguë et des
suites de sa maladie sa famille avec qui
on avait évoqué plusieurs mois de
traitement n'y comprend rien nous dans
nos têtes hostel premiers mois puis
après ça on peut décider des prochaines
étapes
c'était un choc quand les parties
c'était comme c'était comme cauchemar
jennyfer et sa famille avaient amassé 75
mille dollars dans des activités
bénéfices la recherche contre le cancer
ils y croyaient et il croit encore
j'espère que qu'est ce qu'on a fait
qu'est-ce que jennifer a fait l'essai
temps de traitement ça va être utilisé
pour ge pour du bon pour pour l'un des
meilleurs informations pour le futur
mais il faut tenir en compte qu'il ya
les humains
on teste les emails qu'est ce qui est
important ce que l'on veut pas être des
cobayes ou si on est des cobayes qu'on
le sache
[Musique]
fin septembre 2016
trois mois après le décès de jennyfer
guillaume daret cinq ans pourrait bien
être le prochain patient qu'est ce qu'on
vous a dit sur les patients précédent
arrivant je peux parler que donc pas sa
nouvelle bière vin on se dit que c'était
expérimental
on ne va jamais parlé des hauts bassins
de toute façon la mère de guillaume
aurait tout accepter toute étude de tout
traitement qui aurait peut-être pu
sauver son fils intacte ma main mon cas
on regarde s'il y avait un pour cent de
chance voici on sait jamais jusqu'à
dernière minute de moi jveux séparés
parce qu'elles touchent des revirements
d'humeur ça existe les parents du petit
guillaume y avait tellement d'espoir les
dizaines de métiers nous ont dit que ça
allait de l'améliorer et que cela irait
beaucoup mieux abri
je m'en souviens parce que moi
j'essayais de préparer à la fin de
chaque fois ça va aller bien
ce trade center vous vous en étiez ou
par rapport à votre épouse qui était
enthousiaste moi je disais oui pour elle
parce que l'art est parfaite
vous vouliez pas que votre fils soit
considéré comme un air de laboratoire je
les bus quand même sourit blanche dans
un aquarium
comme tous les parents ceux de guillaume
ont signé le consentement écrit un
document qui résume la démarche les
bénéfices attendus et les risques
[Musique]
c'est incroyablement évasif l'éthicien
johnatan qui m'amène à réviser pour nous
le document d'une quinzaine de pages
il s'étonne que le consentement écrit
évoquent la possibilité d'une diminution
de la maladie ce qu'il aurait plutôt
fallu l'élire selon lui c'est une phrase
comme celle ci dit philippe roques la
superstar et là si vous participez à
l'étude la possibilité de guérir ou de
prolonger votre vie est très très
improbable mais vous pourriez aider à
faire progresser notre compréhension de
votre mail est nulle part dans ce
consentement est il indiqué que les
chances de survie sont extrêmement
faibles
les parents de guillaume le signe le 27
septembre 2016
[Musique]
très faible
et à part leur charme
pas tous mais certains conserver une
peau bien longtemps après les marchés
que ça prenait tout pour donner son bain
inventec jane guillaume avait subi six
traitements de chimio pour contrôler une
leucémie incontrôlable
comment peut-on justifier que patients
dans cet état là qui peut même pas
arrêté son traitement ne serait ce que
quelques jours puce embarquée dans une
étude comme ça si la leucémie est arrivé
au point où elle est complètement
incontrôlable
le patient devrait même pas entré dans
les ordres
et effectivement le jour de son
admission à des djeun les reins de
guillaume fonctionne très mal si mal
qu'il est exclu de l'étude
temporairement les médecins donnent à
nouveau le feu vert le 29 septembre
ce jour là les résultats révèlent un
problème la lipase une ancienne du
pancréas dépasse les limites permises au
protocole mais pas suffisamment pour
inquiéter le médecin guillaume entre
dans l'étude
c'est une erreur de l'équipe de
chercheurs selon notre expert
mvr si le protocole prévoit un niveau de
lipase maximale il faut respecter ça on
ne peut pas contourner protocole et
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
le patient n'aurait pas dû être admis
dans l'étude mais guillaume est entré
dans l'étude
il sera le sixième et dernier patient
après la pause les conditions d'hygiène
choquant de la chambre d'hôpital du
petit guillaume le traitement de
guillaume ne durera finalement que cinq
jours
comme pour la plupart des patients il a
fallu arrêter dagg jane prématurément
car la leucémie est revenu en force
pendant qu'une autre menace se cachait
dans les tuiles du plafond je donne le
bain à mon garçon championne de laver
puis à un moment donné je me lève les
yeux au plafond
je tombais caisse massacre un ascenseur
les tuiles au plafond était toute
plainte de moins
c'était un oasis au désabonnement après
les tul au plafond
j'ai sorti mon départ
les sachets toute la plage était opposé
un ferme en effet remis logent deux
événements des six est anormal que dans
une chambre d'enfant pas de système
immunitaire qu'on a des tuiles qui sont
pas seuls
le personnel condamne la porte de la
salle de bains et son grillage avec du
ruban adhésif et une serviette
on offre à la famille de changer de
champ mais comme c'est la seule pièce
familiale disponibles il décide de
rester
est ce qu'on vous a dit quand vous avez
signalé des moisissures au plafond que
fallait que vous sortiez parce que
c'était dangereux
ce centre en son nom non mais pour
personnes qui nous ont dit que ça
pourrait être dangereux pour lui en
quelques jours
[Musique]
c'était le 7 octobre 2005 le 10 octobre
avec un supporter des petits points qui
se transforme en croûte et se mettent à
proliférer de jour en jour l'aml par
tout le monde devrait même incident
il souffrait le martyre des lésions
cutanées douloureuses celui ronger la
cloison nasale se fait des trous dans
les eaux c'était horrible
la clé finalement m essai qui nous voir
mais ça guillaume la table tant qu ils
ne voient qu'à quelques uns des singes
espagne c'est parce que je pensais ça
ressemble à face aux champignons mais il
faut pas que ce soit ça je vous dis faut
pour ça soit ça c'était ça un champignon
très rare le fusarium ça c'est une
culture d'un funérarium
il s'agit d'un champignon filamenteux le
docteur michel laverdière a dirigé le
département d'infectiologie de l'hôpital
maisonneuve rosemont
pendant 17 ans nous lui avons demandé si
ce plafond pouvait être responsable de
cette infection
évidemment la seule façon de le savoir
ben ça arrêtez de prendre près de 20 des
deuils cultiver landrellec faire
l'équation de cause à effet ben oui
c'est possible que ce soit à l'hôpital
n'a pas fait analyser la tuile du
plafond on ne saura donc jamais ce qui
s'y cachaient est-ce que c'était pas
logique de vouloir la tester pour savoir
qu'est ce qui avait là-dedans
ça paraît logique comme ça quand vous
l'exprimez comme ça mais de fait comme
ce sont des infections qui sont
transmises par l'est en tête l'air selon
sainte-justine des analyses de l'air
n'ont pas détecté de traces de
champignon filamenteux est-ce qu'on
reconnaît quand même qui avait une
situation là qui était potentiellement
dangereuses dans de mettre un enfant
immunosupprimées dans une chambre où il
y avait des tuiles brune au plafond dans
la salle de bain à partir du moment où
quand on regarde dans l'air on trouve
pas de champignons c'est pas juste une
tache sur une tuile qui va nous faire
décider que c'est dangereux
je chante danse à la main comme ça il y
avait un enfant immunosupprimées qui
prenait son bain en dessous je ne peux
que vous répétez que dans l'ère de la
chambre il n'y avait pas de maudit sur
le docteur laverdière reste formel un
tel plafond de salle de bains n'avait
pas sa place dans une unité d'enfants du
cimic
c'est sûr que c'est une situation qui
est dangereux une situation où
l'individu en question qui se retrouvent
dans cet environnement là peut aspirer
des ces sports lors de la moitié sud
sont en suspension et développer des
infections fulminante éventuellement
même fatale de peau beaucoup plus
vulnérable que tout patient de ces mecs
sains globules blancs du ranch
chimiothérapie la fusariose a ravagé le
corps de guillaume
mais jusqu'à récemment ses parents ne
savais pas jusqu'à quel point
vous avez fait venir le dossier médical
qu'est ce que vous avez trouvé leur
écoute
il y en a tellement côté quelques pages
mais j'ai tombé sur une feuille de stats
cas de décès sa marque est comme la
cause 17 le fusariose donc l'infection
avec jacky fait que c'est vraiment sorti
ouais mais bon j'avais jamais subir
mascate où l on vous l'avait pas dit
nécessairement non je devine est aussi
mis du coeur
comme en sport ou presque deux ans après
la mort de leur fils c'est maintenant
l'heure des bilans
à fond leur faire un pas que j'accepte
carmen parce que je me dis
dans ses propos finesse deux courses
étaient là pour nous c'est de conseil
c'était pour sa mère la dernière chance
de retrouver le guillaume d'avant celui
qu'elle appelait sa pirouette mais pour
son père l'étude et jane représente une
étape de trous ça confirme les deux que
je vais c'est quand tantôt josé dit
qu'ils prennent acquise maman go pour le
laboratoire avait la preuve terrible à
gauche et c'est ce que je pense
[Musique]
la suspension de l'étude après la mort
de guillaume n'a pas mis fin à la saga
des jane tout au long de 2010 cette
sainte justine a cherché à faire
renverser la décision de santé canada
nous avons obtenu une grande partie de
la correspondance entre les deux
institutions en mars juin et novembre
santé canada sommes les chercheurs
d'expliquer leurs erreurs et de changer
leurs procédures c'est étrange très
étrange ne connais pas le fonctionnement
de santé canada et aux états unis
on ne se serait pas engagée dans un
dialogue on aurait fermé ça tout de
suite j'ai trouvé santé canada patients
en effet deux ans après l'inspection
santé canada continue d'analyser les
informations venant d'un expert mandaté
par sainte justine
l'agencé considère maintenant que les
décès ont été causés par la maladie et
que les effets secondaires comme les
infections fongiques étaient conformes
au protocole mais la question se pose
toujours
fallait-il que l'équipe signal ses
effets secondaires
oui dit santé canada pour qui la
fréquence des infections était
inhabituel lagence convient toutefois
qu'il ya là une zone grise mais santé
canada maintient encore aujourd'hui
qu'il était approprié de suspendre les
essais cliniques
considérant les résultats de
l'inspection est ce que les parents
n'auraient pas dû être mis au courant
parce que c'est parce avec john c'est
une question qu'on s'est posée comme
notre interprétation des fêtes qu'on
maintient toujours et c'est que vous
n'avez pas mis en danger les enfants
qu'on n'a pas eu d'impact sur la survie
n'était pas nécessaire d'appeler les
familles pour les arbustes et avec ça
qui ici n'a pas fait son devoir de
surveillance le comité d'éthique de
sainte-justine chargé de s'assurer que
les participants sont protégés ne semble
pas avoir été mise au courant des
problèmes de dettes jane à l'époque ce
sont les chercheurs qui une fois
convoqués ont rassuré le comité
d'éthique
tous les experts après échange avec
l'équipe de recherche en sont venus à la
conclusion que la sécurité des enfants
n'avait pas été mise en péril dans
l'étude ok contre en danse 4,36 à santé
canada exactement
il faut surveiller l'intérêt des
patients mais aussi l'exactitude des
données de recherche
c'est en principe le travail d'une firme
externe et indépendante
une étape trop coûteuse pour sainte
justine qui n'étaient pas financés par
une compagnie pharmaceutique
alors qu'ils surveillaient les données
un employé de l'hôpital
le gestionnaire de l'étude pour le
chercheur john est une fine lui c'est
inacceptable ex moment il faut une
surveillance indépendante des études la
recherche médicale est beaucoup plus
exigeante que donc la question se pose
est-ce qu'une institution qui n'a pas
l'expérience et l'expertisé pour une
étude de phase un devrait mener une
étude de phase
à moins d'être moniteur est correct
sainte-justine dit vouloir conserver son
mode de surveillance alain terme tout en
l'isolant du centre de recherche
mais pour le reste l'institution
persiste et signe je pense que santé
canada avait une compression incomplet
de certains aspects de l'essai clinique
il ya eu beaucoup d'incompréhension de
la part de santé canada quant à l'essai
clinique c'était des questions d'ordre
administratif
mais allez vous relancer jane je pense
ça serait dommage de priver les enfants
du québec de ce genre de thérapies
innovantes
est-ce que j'aurais mis mon fils dans
cette étude je pense pas parce que le
niveau des risques mentionnés le manque
de clarté de la science le monde
potentiel bénéfice quelconque et le
russe que man enfin devenu plus malades
à mon avis sur cette pièce que de les
aider à décider avec tous les jt
possible donc d'abord ne pas nuire
exactement
[Musique]
j'espère que vous avez apprécié
l'enquète de ce soir pour nous
transmettre des informations rendez-vous
sur notre page web où notre plateforme
sécurisée source anonyme au nom de toute
l'équipe merci beaucoup d'avoir été là
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour
une eau propre
[Musique]